there's a new warning about a rapidly
growing phone scam this morning
criminals are calling you pretending to
be from the Social Security
Administration that'll get your
attention the Federal Trade Commission
says they want your social security
number and they want your money too the
scheme has already cost consumers
millions of dollars Anna Warner is here
to show us why the caller's seem so
genuine Anna good morning good morning
well this new scam has trick consumers
out of 19 million dollars in the past
year compare that to the similar IRS
phone scam that netted the fraudsters 17
million dollars in its peak year the
scammers are using authentic-looking
caller ID to dupe their victims the scam
starts with a phone call regarding to
your social security number
Wayne Chertoff got a call from a woman
he only picked up because his caller ID
told him the Social Security
Administration was calling she said that
my social security number someone was
using my name and social security number
to send thousands of dollars to Mexico
and Colombia and that I had four
different bank accounts in Texas I said
I've never been to Texas and my entire
life and she says well you have an
arrest warrant out there to get rid of
the warrant he followed her instructions
buying fourteen hundred dollars worth of
Google Play cards at this drugstore then
giving the numbers off the back of the
cards to the scammers over the phone she
told him he'd get the money back he
never did
Monica vaca is with the FTC they make
you feel like you're in trouble
and you've got to do something about it
some seventy six thousand people have
complained to the Federal Trade
Commission about the scam about 36
thousand of them in the past two months
people have their guard down and they're
more likely to believe that it is in
fact the Social Security Administration
that's calling when in fact of course
it's not it's a scammer okay so the FTC
wants people to know the Social Security
Administration will never threaten to
cancel your benefits it'll never tell
you to wire money send cash put money on
gift cards
the FTC says if someone calls asking you
to do those things it's
a scammer every time but isn't caller-id
supposed to help you in a situation like
this yeah so believe it or not that's
true and the FTC is now saying don't
trust your caller ID Wow
so the first scam is to the caller ID
company yeah well you're assuring that
well some they're saying that in the
future they'll be able to call you and
it'll say mom and you'll pick up and it
won't be your mom which is is that you
mom that's a good reason so masculine
now this has not been comforting Hanna
but it was good to see you at the table
thank you